All week long, we've been dishing
out tips and tricks to viewers like you
who may just love design or have a design dilemma.
And it is time for a very special design by Drew.
We heard from a husband and wife
who were looking for ways to transform their bedroom
in their forever home.
Oh, this is so fun.
Take a look.
I'm Lily.
This is my husband, Zach.
We met on set at work.
I do hair styling for film and TV
and do the special effects.
Little did we know it slowed down for the whole world,
and we were out of a job.
Yep.
The pandemic changed everything.
When we had to pull out of our mortgage,
his parents decided they needed to sell his childhood home.
It opened up the doors
and we decided to relocate north of the city.
The house has been updated probably
in a little over 40 years.
There was nothing that Lily really thoroughly liked
about the house.
Other than where it was.
We ended up tearing out most of the house
and made it more suitable for our taste
and our interest.
What we needed and stuff.
We had our first born Oliver, who's amazing.
We had a lot of catching up to do once he was born.
And that's kind of where all our focus has been
on the last, what year and a half.
His nursery is like the only room that's been complete.
Our master has nothing, but a broken bed.
He gets in bed, I just like slowly roll over to his side.
'Cause it's a broken lop-sided bed.
But that's what we've had for over a year.
It works.
But Oliver has his room set up
and he's happy and that's what matters.
But would be really nice to have just a alone time together.
Please help us with our master bedroom.
We could really use peace and quiet and tranquility.
Please help us get our space back.
(audience clapping)
Please welcome Lily and Zach Maggio.
Hi guys.
I'm already crying.
Oh yes, oh the hormones must be raging.
Totally.
I love Zach,
I mean the childhood home.
Yeah.
Tell me about this.
It's awesome.
So I grew up there.
I had an older brother and older sister.
Growing up there,
I never realized how special it was.
Now living there each day
I get to see my son have the same memories that kinda I had.
And then a couple, probably about six months ago,
it really dawned on me when my sister,
yeah, my sister, my mother, and my sister's son
were running through the backyard
and my mom was chasing both of them.
So that was something special to me.
Oh my God.
I'm just so glad that your kids
are getting this opportunity.
Yeah.
It's really amazing.
Why haven't you had time to focus on the bedroom?
I feel like the answer is obvious.
Well with COVID, not having a job for a year.
Right?
And then his ankle, he hurt his ankle that year.
And then I, we got so lucky.
It was so quick.
So yeah, so we just haven't had a chance.
I don't even know how our bedroom encouraged this.
(audience laughing)
But it did.
(audience clapping)
Well, if it's okay,
I looked at the before pictures of your bedroom.
Yes.
And I got really inspired.
Very excited.
Okay, I really got into it.
I got really inspired
and I sort of did some design first
for you guys.
So I redid your bedroom.
Is that okay?
Yeah.
We're so excited.
Would you like to see it?
Thank you so much.
(upbeat music)